-You were not always --
At a young age,
people probably assumed
that you were talking about
international news
from behind a desk,
but you --
-Yeah.
-Your first on-camera job
was you were in an adaptation of
Charles Dickens' "Bleak House."
-So, that is actually true.
[ Laughter ]
-You know what? That's true.
We do have to hammer home
that that's true,
'cause that sounds like a joke
you would make.
-It also sounds
like an offensive stereotype
about a British person.
"You were all probably in
Dickensian dramas growing up."
Sadly, I was.
So, yeah.
No one has really found this out
here other than your staff.
-Here's a photo.
-This is it.
-Yeah.
[ Audience "Awws" ]
Yeah, that's right.
This is what the President
has done to me.
[ Laughter ]
Look, there's a child
with light in his eyes there.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, so...
Basically,
when I was 6 years old,
the BBC was shooting
a costume drama
called "Bleak House"
nearby my school,
and they wanted a kid
with dark hair and brown eyes,
and I was two for two on that.
So, yeah, I was in this, like,
very, very lavish
Dickensian drama for the BBC
with, like, Dame Diana Rigg.
I didn't understand
what anything was.
I didn't know
what was happening.
They just said,
"Do you want to do this?"
I said, "Is it
at the same time as school?"
They said, "Yes,
you'll have to leave school,"
and I said yes before
they ended that conversation.
Yeah, it was
a very, very weird experience.
-Here's a clip.
I believe your character's name
is Felix.
-That's right.
I was Felix Pardiggle,
and I'm an orphan.
-Okay.
-Yeah.
-You may have seen the names
of my five boys
printed on a subscription list.
Felix, eight pence,
to the Superannuated Widows.
-Yes.
-Wow, really good.
Really good.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you.
Thank you.
-That is like one more element
of the stereotype,
is that you played an orphan.
[ Laughter ]
-It is so offensive.
If I'd spent half my childhood
up a chimney,
that's the only way
that you could make that
more reductive view
of British people.
The amazing thing
about that scene,
the only thing I remember
about it is them saying,
"Hey, you need
to act bored now."
And I remember thinking,
"Oh, that's okay.
I am bored."
[ Laughter ]
-My parents watched a ton of PBS
when we were growing up.
They watched
a ton of costume dramas.
Every one of them,
from my perspective,
could've been called
"Bleak House."
-That is absolutely fair.
That's right.
That's an
all-encompassing title.
Actually, the only other thing
I remember from that
was Diana Rigg,
who was, like, one of the great
British actresses, she gave me
aniseed balls on set.
-I don't know --
What are aniseed balls?
-You don't have
aniseed balls here?
-No.
-Right, 'cause you value flavor.
[ Laughter ]
Is anyone here from Britain?
-Yes.
-Yeah,
do you remember aniseed balls?
-I do, indeed.
-Yeah, were they pleasant
to put in your face?
-No, they're disgusting.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Right. They are --
-[ Laughing ]
-They are absolutely disgusting.
-And then what --
And when you --
[ Laughter ]
By the way that's the most --
I've never seen someone
so effectively interact
with an audience member
on our show.
[ Laughter ]
Like, you were so clear --
-Yeah, yeah.
That is the way
that British people
reminisce about their past.
"Do you remember that?"
"Yes, it was awful."
"Me too."
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]